i'm gonna present this award and i trust
that you people will stay 500 feet away
from me
just playing quest love says what
everyone is thinking at the 2022 grammy
awards cracking a joke about will
smith's oscar slap we're in vegas look
at this you know people are doing shots
i mean last year people were doing shots
but it was more moderna and pfizer this
time we're back in the mix but kicking
off the jokes earlier in the night host
trevor noah olivia rodrigo i saw olivia
rodrigo myself yeah she was getting
carted and she had to show a bounce on
her actual driver's license it was like
history people acknowledging the
elephant in the room we're gonna be
listening to some music we're gonna be
dancing we're gonna be singing we're
gonna be keeping people's names out of
our mouths and we're gonna be giving out
awards of course this is a reference to
will smith's request to chris rock
[Music]
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television will's outburst followed his
now infamous onstage altercation
trevor noah's joke aside we know he
remains a fan in the aftermath
here's trevor celebrating with will and
jada at vanity fair's oscars after party
another pivotal figure that night
questlove who accepted his trophy
immediately following the controversial
moment fast forward to grammy's night
the newly minted oscar winner gets this
joke in i'm going to present this award
and i trust that you people will stay
500 feet away from me
just playing and the quip follows
questlove's recent tweet sharing his
thoughts about the ongoing pop culture
hot topic he wrote on twitter can we
finally stop talking about it
[Music]
you